こんにちははじめしゃちょーものです今日はですねまぁ最近ちょっと雨が続いてて今僕
は服がありません
なので出かけることもできない子で前だです
それでパンツだけハイとか八郎ズボン履いというかというわけですね
司空がないんですよかっこいい服がでも僕は境地とお出かけしたいんだけどもつくが
ないんで常にも困ってるわけなんですよ
寒いしね大竹はまあ俺にあるもんったらーアルミホイールぐらいじゃないんである意味
ファイルですを作ってみようと思います
捕まらないよね捕まらないと思うよふくたろう
宇野より下手したら記事がいいからさぁきゅっとしたら文堂は服着てるお前らのほうが
つかなるかもしれねえぞ
そうでそうやっぱりそうでアーサー回だった恋
夫がいいよ結構掘って性があるんだけどねこれも感じにきたじゃん
ああ
ねーっ
zone
ねぇあれじゃないんだ悪くはない8悪い0
何がネスターたぶんこのキラキラなんです
だってくれ何が通じる人いないよねこういう音だもうすでにしてる人がいるからね
大丈夫発表しまたある日晴れの服つけた一人ねあっあってが陰ではそれにヤバイな完全
に今年のトレンドだよ
あなたがいい仕上がりだとアーセナル所だよ背中だからどうしよう
無駄にするさまで隠せないんだけどもううわあああああ
バイブいい感じにはなってきたがつくというよりも鎧ない良い
寸胴でさぁ
わー西小口径なってきた気がします
大
うわぁ
ちょっとはずこれはまだの別のヒーローなアルミ不味いザックパック未ない後
上は代々こんな感じでございます次は下だ時間がない
廃油芸何度完成しました
これはネタはいいけどね完全に喪服とさせてるからね
ない中継でちょっとこういう感じがありました
足跡にしてはなかなかだねこの服装で俺が岩からちょっと公園に入ってくるんだよ
んですかまだ捕まらないよ札がネスクだ大丈夫かもよ何度かん
アルミ new アルミホイルで鎧を作っていただければいいのか誰ですなぁ
奇抜ですよすごいん
高森町をなぜきたらというと僕の友達のオフ会があるんでそれにちょっと俺も行きたい
なと思っていたんですけども
ひっつくがなくてまあ今に至るという
たべっ子
をざっすどこにある
入って右て講演うーんそこ
なるほど了解ですをスカイだからねちょっと人が何人かいるからね
この鎧の俺を見てのちょっと反応ね伺いたいともありますあ今実は
はバレてましたっ
ちょいたを出すかぞ
ずっとも大丈夫
視聴者さんがありましたどうですよこれ
根立音下手じゃっ付恥ずかしいとか見られたなぁん
まあこのうちあれですねあ理財局で上がっ
見たいとかを見られてしまったなもうすぐもうすぐですね多分
do it でしたこのこの版のでございって大ファンでしたから a 1タイフーン
いつでも大丈夫第間ハイキャパるっていう
その段階に終えん
どぉすればいいなーっ
すってねなってん
ん
それで鬼太郎話でした
car はぁっはぁっはぁっ
多分
ん